burro d'où je viens, ce
ne sont pas les bidonvilles, nous avons des rois et c'est ce
que je serai mes amis et moi
[Musique]
notre vie est une dichotomie, notre érudit
s'éloignera mais dans le DJ superstar du ghetto
que nous appelons chef d'orchestre parce que Salim
fantastiques une mauvaise mère
[Musique]
tu as un très bon sens avec les mots mec
Marlene Marlene une reine du caramel au beurre nous
croyons que Mylene peut devenir l'
artiste disco numéro un du pays tu vas
être célèbre Je suis sorti du Bronx et
j'ai trouvé un moyen  En tant que citoyen, nous pouvons être
ensemble plus loin quand je nous ai dit que nous étions
sans maison Zeek, tu pourrais être le mec le plus intelligent
de cette école, je ne te verrai jamais
comme un égal
ce soir, je me retrouve dans un endroit étrange,
vais-je faire volte-face mais je laisse mon
mes frères ont disparu sans laisser de trace,
juste une petite courbure, ça pourrait vraiment
être quelque chose.
J'ai du courage, écoute-moi dans cette vie,
si tu veux quelque chose, tu dois
poursuivre
la musique, la seule raison pour laquelle ça ouvrira
des portes pour que tout le monde dise : ferme, il n'y a
pas de trucage.  ce feu de corne d'enfer qui bat
Jar
[Applaudissements]
nous l'avons acheté pour la vie, est-ce qu'il s'est avéré que
les lumières sont incassables, ébranlables comme celles de
vous